per tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono parigi ed oggi siamo su un
video veramente tanto particolare quando
era molto marco marino a casa mia con
suo fratello abbiamo registrato un hai
mai l'avevamo fatto per i fatti nostri
senza registrare quindi era proprio tra
di noi per divertirci solo che a me era
venuta in mente l'idea mettiamo una
videocamera che registra che magari c'è
qualche cagata e ci esci fuori qualche
video vi faccio questa premessa molto
importante perché durante questo questa
che stai mai in realtà questo gioco si
fa quando si è al tavolo con gli amici
ed è una cosa proprio per passare il
tempo e ad ognuno alla bottiglietta di
birra quando una persona non ha mai
fatto una cosa che un altro dice beve un
sorso dalla bottiglietta si fa così di
base solo che siccome io non ho mai mai
fatto un video dove c'è di mezzo anche
solo un tanto così di birra
lo faccio questa premessa perché non
vorrei mai che diventa co lizzato è una
cosa che avevamo fatto tra di noi amici
come fanno tutti quindi questo era per
evitare i moralisti di sto cazzo quindi
non è un invito a bere né a fare niente
era semplicemente un modo per passare
del tempo con i miei amici e niente vi
lascio al video ragazzuoli buona visione
benvenuti sono mai semplici regole di
tre birre si beve ogni volta che a giro
si dice io non ho mai e dico qualcosa
non ho mai fatto se noi oggi ci sono
hanno fatto davvero bene io ricordiamoci
con la donna aveva fatto perché c'è
gente che io non ho mai respirato mai fa
ho mai fatto iniziato a studiare le loro
liti in casa e gli vogliono le di casa
ma io quindi devo dire una cosa che ho
fatto non hai mai battuto a io devo dire
che non è vero che non hai mai fatto e
non lo è non belli tra dice noi paghiamo
e quindi spetta se l'avete fatta io non
ho mai fatto questo gioco alla salute
sono una persona per la buona sorte
francesco mi arrivò alla salute quando
guarda tu a te un cazzo all'ottava
non me ne bevo birra io non ho mai fatto
fantasie erotiche sul mio stesso sesso
che non dovevi allora io non sapevo che
fosse ma le cose non sono così fosse
nato ragazzi il titolo non sapevo questo
rimasto io no dai passo come possa
finire quale cosa 4 nazione intera
mi spiace sono molto sincero io non mai
scoppiato un brufolo altrui non ho fatto
veramente schifo genera lo scrive come
dice gentile ci ha come hobby al gruppo
l'ora che si vede ke kazzo fa è una
micro chirurgia terra che siamo parlati
io adesso sono nati così io non ho mai
sfruttato uno youtuber per fare
visualizzazione io non mai avuto
l'istinto omicida si commuove quando è
commestibile non vi hanno mai stato in
bocca
mio figlio è semplice mamma mi ha
veramente brutta roba non ho mai
raccolto la merda d'accesso a casa non
ho mai non civile
non ho messaggiato la mia merda per
sapere il gusto il resto io sì proprio
piccolo è stata di merda io non ho mai
anche pensate per le corna delle ragazze
o comunque un ragazzo lavoro ha mai
pensato ha pensato non farlo per far
pagare il saldo va bene ma diventa cosa
basta e non devi toccarti nelle foto di
vista che bacia vandali notifiche a
questo coro è fidanzato basta e normale
usurpato tombe degli umani ed animali
sul senso
no perchè ho visto una ginetta sito
gratuito ma io ci andrò mai le mie
ghiandole natale non volevo che il
piacere
proseguiamo così sentito testimoni in
ambito nazionale ma traber di merda una
pro merda in salvo e un po di fragole
che tocco di ragazzi mi sono messo il
naso in duetti o fatto cioè poco fai le
cose normali telefoni normali che schifo
che farebbe da farlo adesso non ho mai
limonato con una persona senza che mi
piacesse io non ho mai fantasticato
sulla mamma di un amico
anche io da une fatevi sentire strana la
nakheel proprio shock ha votato sì
qualche azione a meno di letti erano mai
rubato una bici mai come mai fatto che
accetterebbe le carte dei pokémon tutto
si svolge su uno sviluppo e un padre dei
volti vogliamo ruby
poco gioco dai una carta non ho mai
risposto male ad un fan
tu lo sapevo del 98 celebri one sì ma
non ho mai visto sto male quindi ragazzi
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto è
stato veramente disastroso tirare fuori
certi argomenti però tra amici questa
roba si fa sempre che tu non la riprende
che non la metta su youtube davanti a 4
milioni di persone però questo è un
altro discorso
quindi ragazzi spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto come mi piace anche i vari
social che come tiziana ci sono i tipici
vediamo il prossimo video dei ragazzi
[Musica]